personen des tages für mich heute karl
lauterbach der gesundheitsminister der
hat mir nicht ganz nebenbei seine corona
strategie gewechselt man muss sagen
nicht nur seine cola strategie sondern
eigentlich die korona strategie der
vergangenen zwei jahre bisher wurden
maßnahmen lockdown maßnahmen alle
einschränkungen eigentlich damit
begründet eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems verhindern zu wollen
also ein kollaps beispielsweise von
kliniken aber heute hat kalt aber etwas
ganz anderes gesagt er hat gesagt es
darf keine lockerungen der aktuellen
corona maßnahmen geben weil es weiterhin
100 bis 150 tote am tag gibt um das ganz
klar zu sagen jeder tote in der pandemie
aber auch jeder andere tote ist ein
toter zu viel das ist ganz klar
aber natürlich wirkt das leben risiken
und auch in dieser pandemie geht es um
eine risikoabwägung denn es gibt
natürlich auch menschen die an grippe
sterben menschen die ein autounfall
erleiden und dann dabei zu tode kommen
also was karl lauterbach hier überhaupt
nicht bedacht hat ist dass es
beispielsweise auch durch die harten
corona maßnahmen viele viele millionen
menschen gibt die leiden die
gesundheitlich leiden ist gefährlich was
karl lauterbach gemacht hat er hat
unterschieden er hat quasi gesagt ein
menschenleben das foto ohne gerettet
werden kann ist wichtiger als ein
menschleben dass beispielsweise durch
ein krebsleiden davor einem krebsleiden
gerettet werden kann das ist ein
falscher weg karl lauterbach das geht
nicht der staat muss menschenwürde
garantieren er kann nicht dass
menschenleben garantieren
ja da muss ich jetzt auch mal direkt
einhalten wenn ich darf ich finde wir
verkennen bei dieser ganzen corona
politik vor allen dingen das ja diese
überlastung der krankenhäuser nicht
corona geschuldet ist sondern
tatsächlich zum einen auch den mangel an
personal geschuldet ist ich kann ich aus
eigener erfahrung gerade sprechen bin
vor fünf mutter geworden und war dann
selbst mal patient im krankenhaus als
ärztin habe das mal live erleben können
und dürfte feststellen dass es auf der
gesamten station zwei krankenschwestern
gab was dazu führte dass er mann
klingelte weil man noch betrübt da lag
niemand gekommen ist keiner kommen
konnte und die sind nicht etwa nicht
gekommen weil das ganze personal krank
ist sondern erstens wer will diesen job
noch machen das ist tatsächlich ein
problem weil die arbeit im krankenhaus
ist hart und wird schlecht bezahlt das
ist de facto so und damit diesen
quarantänemaßnahmen wir natürlich
unglaublich viel rein theoretisch
gesundes personal in quarantäne haben
was nicht zur arbeit kommen darf und wir
sozusagen da wirklich sozusagen der der
katzenschwanz abschneiden also es wird
wirklich schwierig überhaupt noch
wirtschaftlich zu funktionieren als
krankenhaus und mit dieser kursänderung
methode verhindern
ich finde es nur noch absurd also ich
finde es als erster unternehmerin die
politik nur noch absurd und das
vertrauen in diese politik geht gegen
null
absurde politiker als sebastian geisler
also was ich mich dann gefragt hat ist
ja ok karl lauterbach da denkt man der
setzt jetzt auf gesundheitsschutz weil
er halt gesundheitspolitiker ist aber er
sitzt ja offensichtlich ausschließlich
im grunde auf diesen corona schutz und
ist nicht in der lage eine abwägung
nicht mal innerhalb sozusagen der
gesundheitsfrage vorzunehmen wenn ihr es
ihm offensichtlich nach wie vor egal ist
was ist zum beispiel bei der zahl der
suizide psychische erkrankungen usw was
da los ist das muss man doch mal zur
kenntnis nehmen warum ist er nach wie
vor offensichtlich nicht in der lage das
in einer in seine maßnahmen finden hier
mit einzubeziehen das verstehe ich nicht
ich habe mittlerweile den eindruck
wolfgang kubicki hat ja nun vielleicht
sich auch unglücklich eingelassen sagte
in seinem lokal mit bande karl
lauterbach einen spacken na gut hat er
gesagt hat ich würde eher den eindruck
vielleicht ist karl lauterbach ein
anderes entschuldigung dass ich das hier
sage ein fachidiot der sich fest genauso
festgefressen hat diesen diesem corona
maßnahmen ich finde gut dass er sich
stellt er stellt sich hat sich auch bei
bild vom paar tagen wieder gestellt und
auch erklärt zu der kritik daran nur ich
verstehe nicht es gibt doch jetzt nicht
plötzlich ein super grundrecht corona
schutz sondern es gibt doch auch andere
rechte warum bremst diesen mann
eigentlich niemand ein jahr alt sie sind
spd abgeordnete karl lauterbach auch aus
der spd ist ja ihr fraktionskollege ist
meine fraktionskollegen ist natürlich
auch der gesundheitsminister der
bundesregierung aber ich glaube nicht
dass karl lauterbach ein leben quasi das
leben unterschiedlich bewertet hat ja
also leben die von corona gerettet
werden können andere eben ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass er das so deutlich
heute gemacht hat und zwar ganz klar
gesagt er hat gesagt also es gibt 100
bis 150 tote pro tag das sind viel zu
viele tot oder sich einig dass das e
mail reinigt das ist richtig hart aber
wenn man das natürlich jetzt zu ende
führt also dann ist auch 50 tote
eigentlich 50 tote zu viel also wohin
will karl lauterbach bis zu 0 toten das
ist ein ehrbares ziel aber es ist nicht
einzuhalten und die die die probleme die
man hat wenn man bis zu 0 corona toten
am tag kommen möchte ich schnell
vergrößern sich auf anderen bei anderen
nicht immer absolut soll wer in die
krankenhaus problematik die frau rebecca
sie angesprochen hat und da ist es ja so
dass wir gerade die regeln verändert
haben das personal was im
gesundheitssektor arbeitet eben eine
verkürzte quarantäne hat oben um eben
dem sektor nicht auf ihr personal zu
entziehen was ja das mag vielleicht
immer noch hart sein nein bereiche doch
ich will deine uhr muss ich lachen weil
jetzt will ich hatte das jetzt in meiner
praxis tatsächlich auch und für
medizinisches personal gilt dann fünf
tage quarantäne zeit für anderes
personal was im büro sitzt vielleicht
auch alleine oder in der regel in der
lage ist auch menschen zu vermeiden oder
digital zu arbeiten gilt sieben tage
also wo ist da die logik dass ich im
büro oder in anderen bereichen sieben
tage quarantäne und gesundheit
gesundheitswesen wo ich etliche menschen
ihr tag lädt der aber dehoga ist einfach
das quali nicht genannt wird dass die
auch die logik ist einfach so dass quasi
im bereich des geräts gesundheitswesens
ich eine gewisse vorsorge brauche eine
versorgung mit personal weiterhin und
die aufrecht erhalten muss auch in
anderen bereichen der daseinsvorsorge
polizei wasserwerk und so weiter und so
fort sich da halt sagen muss okay
vielleicht wäre aus medizinischer sicht
eine andere tage frist angemessen aber
auch ganz pragmatische sicht um das
system aufrecht zu halten muss ich sagen
ich gehe auf die fünf tage runter der
grundlage fehler wenn die bisherige
grundlage nämlich die überlassung des
gesundheitssystems herr hagen ist es
dann gerechtfertigt diese maßnahmen
weiterhin aufrecht zu haben die wir
haben beispielsweise in einigen
bundesländern immer noch zwei gm handel
in den aller meisten bundesländern noch
zwei geht zum teil plus in der
gastronomie ich halte diese ständige
ziel verschiebung für hochproblematisch
wir haben am anfang wir erinnern uns
2020 gesagt das ziel ist platz und der
käufer also wir wollen die
infektionsgefahr abflachen
dann hat's geist wir wollen die
belastung des gesundheitssystems
verhindern und jetzt heißt es sozusagen
jeder tote ist einer zu viel wenn man
das durchdekliniert bedeutet dass wir
kommen nie mehr aus den maßnahmen raus
und deswegen glaube ich ist es
vernünftig und wir sagen es droht jetzt
keine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
mir dass wir auch von so maßnahmen wie
zweig möglich schnell weg kommen aber
wir haben uns ja die pandemie bekämpfung
auch die politik wie wir sie bekämpfen
mit der neuen bundesregierung ins
parlament zurück geholt bei der angela
merkel war das so dass wurde aber eine
regierungssache auch verordnung wurden
quasi von der bundesregierung
herausgegeben jetzt werden die
verordnung vom bundestag beschlossen und
haben dadurch natürlich viel höhere
legitimation die abgeordnete sind gerade
gewählt von der bevölkerung in der
pandemie zeit heißt sie haben mandat
dafür auch zu entscheiden und das finde
ich sehr sehr demokratischen im märz
werden wir wieder darüber entscheiden
und darüber entscheiden wie wir die
maßnahmen verlängern und wir mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz weiter an wir
sehen ja um deutschland herum gibt es
immer mehr länder die ihre maßnahmen zum
teil sogar komplett abschaffen und
jawohl deutschland sagt der
bundesgesundheitsminister auf keinen
fall es gibt jetzt nicht die zeit dafür
dies zu tun das ist schon sehr sehr
traurig gemerkt wer meine familie ist
halb dänisch und da ist es eben so dass
in der zielgruppe ab 60 jahren also die
zielgruppe die einen bei einer nicht
impfungen auch ein höheres risiko hatten
schweren verlauf zu haben im krankenhaus
so lange auf der its zu landen das wird
dass wir dort eine infektion dass wir
dort eine impfrate von 99 prozent haben
da habe ich dann auch eine andere
grundlage als hier in deutschland zu
sagen ich schaffe diese maßnahmen ab ich
finde es auch schön dass die dänen sehr
flexibel mit diesen regeln umgehen und
sagen wirklich wieder lockern wenn es
die situation nach unserer bewertung
ergibt und wir verschärfen wie danach
haben sie ja auch gemacht quasi als die
die lage eben wieder nicht
kontrollierbar war aber das muss jedes
land für sich bewerten und wie gesagt
die impfung ist eine andere aber um die
logik von karl lauterbach dann einmal
vorzuführen und martin hagen hat ja
gerade schon so ein bisschen angedeutet
würde eigentlich bedeuten man müsste die
zahl der toten ob jetzt in der pandemie
oder vielleicht auch dann einem extrem
harten grippe winter natürlich immer
wieder auf null drücken am ende
bedeutete dass ich darf morgens
eigentlich gar nicht aufstehen ich
formuliere es jetzt mal ganz ganz ganz
knapp sich bei mir schon beim aussteigen
aus dem bett etwas passieren können
spätestens wenn ich auf die straße gehe
wie gesagt ganz wichtig ich formuliere
jetzt salopp könnte mich ein auto
umfahren ich könnte ein ziegel treffen
das kann ja nicht sinn und zweck von
politik sein zu sagen ich will das
risiko
körperlicher versehrtheit für jeden
menschen diesem land so ehrenwert dieses
ziel ist aber auf null reduzieren dann
würde das land komplett zusammenbrechen
es ist also also coruna ist nicht grippe
haben wir hier auch immer wieder
klargestellt nur es ist ja so mir graut
davor mal einfach als gedankenspiel was
wäre wenn die politik jetzt plötzlich
darauf kommt wir bringen euch jetzt auch
noch gut durch die nächste grippewelle
weiter sterben das 20.000 menschen oder
teilweise auch mehr das nicht bezahlen
das ist eine oft so gar nicht bewusst
gewesen wie schlimm auch die die grippe
er sein kann wie die wütet gerade bei
den wirkungsgrad 1000 euro beträgt das
enorme zahlen und dennoch machen wir das
da nicht er ist die frage warum machen
wir das bike ohne balkon irgendwie neu
ist nur cola ist jetzt ja auch gar nicht
mehr so neue kohona wird auch nicht
wieder verschwinden wahrscheinlich das
wird ja das wird eine erkrankung sein
die man sich eben einfangen kann
deswegen ist es mir persönlich wichtig
geimpft und gebuchter zu sein
tatsächlich das ist dabei übrigens auch
was wo ich mal sagen muss dass ich
geimpft und gebuchter bin das ist eine
sache für mich eigentlich zwischen mir
und meinem arzt und nicht zwischen mir
und meinem imbissbesitzer oder so dem
ich jedes mal wieder das zeigen muss
also auch das finde ich sollte jetzt
langsam sehr schnell sollte das enden
das ist auch nicht dienlich nach meiner
meinung dem infektionsschutz
ich finde wir haben uns in dieser
politik völlig verlaufen es ist absurd
was wir veranstalten wenn ich mir
überlege dass wir wirklich immer nur
noch über irgendwelche corona zahlen
sprechen corona tode wo keiner wirklich
auf verifiziert wann ist ein crooner
toter wirklich ein coronator das ist ja
wirklich gestorben dass es das gibt dass
das schlimm ist dass wir das behandeln
müssen das ist doch jetzt lange seit
zwei jahren diskutiert aber was hier
völlig vergessen und das ist das was ich
täglich in der praxis sehe ist dass es
natürlich genau wie sie sagen andere
dinge gibt wir haben kinder die
psychisch traumatisiert sind die den
ganzen tag mit diesem verrückten masken
im unterricht sitzen ärger bekommen wenn
sie am fenster sitzen die mütze auf
haben wir haben menschen die depressiv
sind wir haben menschen die ihren job
verloren haben wir haben existenzen die
brach liegen und wir laufen in eine
wirtschaftliche situation zurück von
keiner von uns hier am tisch sitzen noch
überdenken kann und das finde ich
maximal verteilt